you know I had a video release scheduled
are worked out for the rest this week
and now it's just shot to hell so
today's video was going to be my wrap-up
review for stranger things season 2 and
then tomorrow was going to be my review
of the latest episode of Gotham but
that's all shot the heck because this
and now there's a big Star Wars
announcement that I might have to do
another video on but this I absolutely
have to talk about I can't not so we
finally got our look at what Jodie
Whittaker as the doctor and doctor who
will actually be wearing now I said in
some of my later videos talking about
her casting that I wasn't really gonna
put any judgement on how I thought she
was gonna play it because a I still
don't really know her much as an actress
I've seen like now maybe the first
episode of broadchurch I haven't had
time to get through that thing but even
if I had seen that that doesn't tell me
anything about how she's gonna play this
and I had said that once we actually saw
an outfit that might be a better
indicator of things because really you
think about it the different doctors
what they wore was fairly indicative of
their personalities in a lot of cases
now it's not always easy to ahead of
time look at the outfit and predict how
they're going to behave I'm not sure
too many people guessed how Matt Smith
was gonna behave based off that outfit
but you know sort of looking back go oh
yeah and at the very least that it you
know threw off your expectations and
everything else and certainly with
Capaldi's reveal you know that very
tight buttoned up heat it looked like a
grouchy house Kazem and he was grouchy
at least you know when he first showed
up so here we go with this outfit now
I've had that part of me is thankful
that this news happened middle of the
day as much as I'm annoyed that it threw
my schedule off because I've had the
entirety of my workday to look at and
think about this thing so I have sort of
gone over it we're actually got let's
start at the bottom work our way up the
boots
I like the boots I like when the shoes
kind of don't seem quite right it was
one of the things I liked about the
shoes that David Tennant war despite the
fact that he was generally in a suit so
I I kind of liked those they are there
they're a little heavier than you would
have thought for for somebody like the
doctor and I'm not saying that because
the doctors now alike in general they
look a little heavy or a little sort of
more serious than than I would have
expected out of most incarnations of the
doctor so that's kind of neat there's
something very playful about the gap
between where the boots stop and the
pants begin that I just kind of like it
I have no doubt I am over reading into
some of these details but I mean I've
been looking at this thing all day I'm
going to but like I said there's this
sort of haphazard miss that there's that
yeah these do these things do not go
together I don't care and I like that
and sort of as we're working our way up
I'll mention you can see the TARDIS in
the background and the B insignia the
the st. John Ambulance thing that's gone
it doesn't even look like it's faded it
just looks gone which I don't have too
much to read into except the TARDIS is
looking a little less sort of fresh a
little more beaten up in general so
maybe that's what we're that's coming in
working our way up a little further the
pants in general are fine I like that
there's a little bit of yeah you know
the colour there the blue I kind of like
and then we get to the you know sort of
the the middle there we got the the
shirt the suspenders I'm gonna stick a
pin in that and come back to it then
let's talk to code what I see of the
coat I like I like that it is long
because I just kind of like the doctor
on a long coat in general I mean I even
going back to you know the fourth doctor
didn't to Tom Baker he looked good in a
long coat I think a long coat is a good
look for the doctor almost regardless of
incarnation so I like that I kind of
like again the little bit more color
than we sometimes get so sort of the
silver looking on the outside of it also
exhort of it it is it is kind of what I
said I wanted it's just enough of that
vibe of that initial sort of teaser
outfit which was the hoodie and the coat
so I'm
liking that so coming back to what I
mean you know the hair I'm assuming
that's the hair beekeeping that's the
hairstyle Jodie Whittaker was already
sporting nothing new there looks fine so
the shirt and the suspenders
um the principle behind it I totally dig
and there's a certain thing that that
this does that I enjoy now first of all
I like the suspenders because they're
anachronistic I like an anachronistic
touch on the doctor I mean the well duh
the eleventh Doctor was just drenched in
anachronism but you know the bowtie
would have been the big one for him with
Capaldi's doctor just sort of that
really tight buttoned up no collar shirt
that was a little like huh that's a
little odd and suspenders are just not
something people really wear anymore so
I'm kind of down with that in theory and
sort of the band that goes across on the
shirt the the effect of the suspenders
and the placement for that horizontal
strip is bringing a relatively subtle
emphasis to her curves because the look
overall is not particularly gendered
honestly you could slap that outfit on a
guy and it wouldn't be like dude that
guy's in woman's clothes so I mean I
like that in generals it's not really
gendered one way or the other
particularly severely but what sort of
gives you the indicator of her
femininity is a little bit of body shape
indicated by that horizontal and the
suspenders because suspenders have to
curve just a little around her bust and
it's sort of framed there so without
being like cleavage they give her a
little bit of shape to the top to the
bust without making it feel like they're
emphasizing making her trying to look
big chested or anything like that so I
like that it is emphasis on a feminine
aspect without like highlighting it so
I'm fine with all that however I cannot
ignore my first instinct when I saw this
and that was it's Mork I'm not saying I
can't overlook that
I can't get over that I think I can I
think I probably already have but the
fact that that was my first reaction
that's not that that bugs me a little
bit now to be fair Mork which was Robin
Williams breakout role in the 70s on TV
them from Mork & Mindy that's that's a
dated cultural reference point I I don't
think that Mork has stayed in the
popular consciousness I mean obviously
you know Ron Williams himself went way
beyond that role and he's known for
other things way before he's known for
that so certainly I'm not sure if people
any younger than me really have that as
a cultural touchstone because if I me
honestly the only reason I know it is
because I'm old enough to remember when
Nick at night primarily ran older
sitcoms so that's was sort of how I knew
it you know so if I'm being fair there
is probably a decent chunk of the
audience that aren't even gonna catch
that as a potential reference and I
don't think it's deliberate because the
in the details they don't match up
because Mork yohio he usually had
horizontal striped shirt but it was
stripes all the way down and he had
rainbow suspenders in this case the
suspenders are solid color and it's the
strike it isn't even a rainbow so anyone
who's going like she's got the pride
play across it no she doesn't it's not a
full rainbow it's not the pride yeah I
don't know if now that I've gone off on
a mini tangent on that I actually don't
know what the overall response and
reaction to this outfit is I have gone
out of my way to not look at what people
think about this thing because I wanted
to get my thoughts out in my opinion out
based on my reaction so I'm presuming
that there's some folks out there who
are saying that I could be wrong that
would be wonderful that would be amazing
if I'm if I'm completely wrong about
people saying oh she's got the pride
flag across her chest because that would
mean that the fandom is behaving better
than I expect them to
so that would be awesome but I kind of
suspect some people are at least saying
it as a joke if not dead serious and
even as a joke come on
but anyways but even though it isn't an
actual rainbow that multi it's got
multiple colors in a horizontal you know
parallel fashion plus the suspenders it
still conjures up that image now that
having been said in terms of cultural
touchstones that you're going to grab on
to Mork is at the very least an alien so
you know as goofy as a point of
reference as that is it is at least the
matically relevant so uh yeah that's
kind of it as I said I as much as that
was my first reaction I kind of it uh
the more I think about it the more I I'm
kind of already over it I mean that said
if that if like you really can't shake
the image of Robin Williams in rainbow
suspenders out of your head when you
look at this I mean that's that's gonna
suck for you and I and I'm not saying
that that you're wrong to hold that
opinion I'm hoping you can get over it
because like I said I actually why when
I divorce myself from that specific
issue I like the look overall I like the
feel I like the vibe there's there's
just enough touches of it almost feels
like in a certain way that it it's
almost like a a toned-down second take
on Colin Baker's doctor was like let's
get some more color in there let's get a
little more vibrant let's have some
mismatched elements but on a much more
subtle scale that visually doesn't
assault you the way that Colin Baker's
outfit did and so I'm kind of getting
that vibe a little bit um which actually
that'd be that'll be interesting if she
sort of has a more abrasive take like
Baker was and she's not just you know
softer just cuz it's a woman though
that's just a random thought off down my
head who knows we'll see we'll find out
you know what you know I think helps
solidify that i and I kind of am over my
initial gut reaction on this is that I
saw like a bunch of the fan art that's
already been made and I'm looking at
that going I like it that's kind of cute
this kind of adventurous this kind of
yeah I'm digging it
so like in a way seeing this look get
reinterpreted by fans who do fan art and
kind of made me go yeah okay because
that's always the that's always part of
the problem with these images the single
image reveals of looks for characters
which is that it locks you into whatever
this angle and this mood that they chose
and you really zero in on that and you
can sometimes lose the thread of the
possibilities of what the thing looks
like in motion from other angles in
different lighting and different just
settings and vibes and feels and because
you just you spend so much time staring
at this one image and just looking a fan
or kind of help me go oh yeah yeah okay
and maybe that's a that's an odd thing
to help me along but it honestly it kind
of did so that's where I am
I had my initial reaction because of the
more connection so I I acknowledge that
that's there I acknowledge that if you
know that as a cultural standing and
touchstone and and Anna point of
reference it makes it a little bit weird
and it and admittedly it was something
that I had to get over but once I did
know I'm good with this look and I'll be
like I said I'll be really curious I
think the question now is whether the
the sort of pops of colour and then the
you know little little bits of weirdness
like the use of the suspenders or the
fact that the pants are too short and
being matched with heavy boots whether
all of this is an indication of
something or subversion towards how
she's going to play cuz again think of
Colin Baker his outfit was bright and
colorful but he himself was incredibly
you know grumpy and harsh and all this
other stuff so is how she's gonna play
it going to play into her looker is her
look in contrast to it so there's still
a lot of possibilities about it I do
like that the feel of this is colorful
and I like that they didn't just
photograph her against a white
background like they did with Capaldi's
first reveal I like that they've got a
setting she's in nature she's in grass
there's the TARDIS a little bit of Sun
setting Oh
it's kind of a nice I like the whole
vibe though the whole feel of the thing
but like is that it did require me
getting over something so that's where I
land it's honestly as far as the stuff
that has come up I come out about what's
happening for the next series it's this
look is probably the thing that I have
the most confidence in because the
casting at this point I I'm pretty much
completely over the fact that it's a
woman her as an actress I don't know so
I don't have a call either way Chibnall
I'm a little nervous about because his
writing on the show I haven't been a
huge fan of but he's also run other
shows that are supposed to that are
supposedly very good so but I'm a little
iffy on that they're doing three
companions I have I'm worried about that
being an overcrowded TARDIS all this
stuff could work but I feel like
everything else has there's more reasons
for me to be concerned and I look at
this and like there was one reason for
me to be concerned the the Mork thing
and I got over it so for me this is like
the firmest yeah no I I don't really
have a problem with this once I got over
that first thing so yeah pretty happy
with this I suppose what are your
thoughts now that I've rambled on I'm
pretty sure I've talked circles and come
back and made the same point like three
or four or ten times what are your
thoughts on all this whatever they are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
Council of geeks give a listen to the
Council of geese podcast that is
available on iTunes and stitcher also
I'm one half of the punch like a girl
podcast that is a presentation of the
fire and water podcast network Fire and
Water podcast comm and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]